welcome to this field playing
international master bullet master
bullet master was that sorriness narayan
narayan narayan on bow difficult he is
the bullet master what does he have in
one minute to 555 ok that's pretty high
highest rating ok so i went for Kirk on
here and the advance ok amazing yeah
this guy has thousands of games rly
thousands and I never played him 500
five-minute games and he's not the
quickest ever that's surprising
considering he's the bullet master
yeah the short variation has always been
one of the main tries and the last
couple of years and yeah let's see wow
really it's not something you see every
day at least in my experience with the
car account never say never solve before
Mia interesting so takes put the night
up to be fine let's see a pit we should
be seven I guess maybe night / 27 12 5
that's probably okay can I trade this I
mean I've got less space or trade
something that I welcome okay g6 why not
why not okay seeking their so it's not a
6 an idea I don't think so no not yet
this my king feels reasonably safe on
the on the Kings side and on the King
side on the queenside so what is he
doing like g3 f4 may be possible so
let's retreat the Queen and give my
bishop the e7 square to go to ok see
going from 95 no not yet
talk about a closed position yeah that's
one of them one of the most most closed
positions that that's a weird way to put
it probably very incorrect English and
that I have that I had gym I'm just
putting this here on on the H file
really cannot do much but that the same
is applying for wide I can put the night
on see for now it's this don't know this
some kind of achievement I don't don't
know
hey just wants to wait for a good moment
to sacrifice can I take on before here
in this position it's close actually he
has such a weird setup that it might
work good ton of checks so it's not
enough but it's close very close
Knight takes d5 don't tell me I stumbled
into that one maybe I should have
chicken f3 first mmm 95 rook f 397 rook
d three nights ok it's ok i guess i
didn't want to spend more time and then
lose on time
okay so special g5 an idea maybe an to
get the bishop involved I can take on
before by the way is this this is good
right this is good pawn takes 94 and
Queen takes Queen evade but check no
that's not going to that not going to go
check go unpunished I don't believe that
check so let's give a ton of checks ha
ha ha jo offered ah you offered and must
be joking so 94 or I can also check it
there that's it's quite nice actually
it's running into our checks and not let
Carol that flies pestering me so let's
no my queen is hanging so start with
this check I can also check first with
check here but of course i'm not drawing
that's that's kind of kind of strange
this idea check so time warning night he
is again check checking him to create
check check
Knight takes f5 maybe Knight a5 Queen g2
is made and this rook g3 made as well so
look g3
checks do that and Queenie five it also
seems quite good
wait check hmm what is easiest here
actually this is chester maybe not maybe
not actually how stupid i thought his
maid is not made uh he actually is 93
king edge to Queen h4 made but still
that was far too complicated they don't
believe this crap ah and I'm losing on
time I'm just such an idiot black that's
on I'm such an idiot how I don't I don't
believe it check check check it simply
couldn't could you meet them so what is
the maid Rugare to estimate uh okay yeah
okay that's not okay it's not difficult
yes but with this little child jesus
made you can overlook yeah check check
what a shame what a shame really the
whole game you were so just shuffling
around and doing basically nothing and
then you overlook this one I'm came
before it's just nuts I mean check check
just chance check they have one minute
this is just terrible this is to Cheryl
or not not winning this and I should
just play quicker the thing is that I'm
winning this with any move really it
just that one you cannot win it is to
lose on time check I should just just do
this quicker anything which is really
Queenie five is also made yeah yeah yeah
EF is the point the
made on a jade was just a matter of time
there's not much to say about this game
he just played it in a way that um yeah
like here I'm totally safe on the
queenside antibes yeah advances on the
Kings side which leads to a situation
where black can just sit and wait I
cannot do much here but of course it's
it so I'm so so solid that it should
should never be a problem to look like
you know whenever he pushes chief oh I'm
entering on the H file and well then
then you blundered into into this and I
was just far too far to show them check
check check out here chest which I just
spent all that time it was okay up to
here check check check check whether
spend quiet time with this Queen Queenie
forbus just I took this fast too long
yet every move wins yeah really every
move windsor rook h3 look G 193 is
easiest how idiotic can you be every
move windsor check Jim
yeah of course with any any kind of
increment this this whole thing as a
joke but it's yeah I didn't see rookie
after this actually is a quick made yeah
so I would have I would have managed
here he only has a smooth and now
anything here for night age form and
made them okay well thanks for watching